hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar T cells in covid-19 translating
research findings into clinical options
I am Marie Stone of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by miltoni biotech to learn more visit
miltenibiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
I'd like to now welcome our speakers Dr
Lorenz Fula PhD Global products manager
for antigen and virus specific T cells
miltoni biotech and Dr Houston longveld
global product manager milteni biotech
Dr Fuller and Dr langveld you may now
begin your presentation
yes welcome everybody to today's webinar
on T cells in covid-19 translating
research findings into clinical options
I'm Lawrence and I'm a product manager
for enter specific T cells so the
webinar today will have two parts in in
first part I will show you our complete
workflow and products that have been
developed to study T cells specifically
in zarzko V2 infections but also in
other contexts in the second part
Kirsten dunfeld product manager for cell
therapy will show you
how to use cell therapy to fight
infections such as our sco V2 and she
will also highlight some pre-clinical
data that has been published recently so
let's start
but before we start I would like to ask
you to please acknowledge the display
disclaimer
so here you see today's agenda so we
actually have six main points so in the
first part I will start with a brief
introduction then introduce you to our
workflow for the analysis of antigen
viral specific T cells and then show you
our product solutions that we have
developed for this workflow in the
second part Kirsten will show you how to
use cell therapy to fight infections
then also here introduce you to our
products that can be used for very Cell
Therapy applications and then finish
with some highlighted clinical data that
has been recently published and I also
just want to let you know that we will
make the slides available after the
session enter the slides are also very
interactive so whenever you see like
these orange circles or blue circles
here that you can see here on the top
also these little pink hands you can
just click on it and then you will find
more information
so why do we need to study the immune
system in covid-19 in more detail well
of course it is important to know that
we have to study the entire immune
response to the ASP of two infections in
order to understand the disease as
indeed all the immune cells so for
example myeloid cells as well as
lymphocytes so T and B cells could play
a critical role in disease outcome and
also its final clearance some mileage
cells for example macrophages could also
play a detrimental role in the disease
and therefore could be studied as normal
drug targets
so lymphocytes on the other hand so tnb
cells actually play a key role in the
defense against the disease but are also
responsible for building up
immunological memory which will then in
the end give us protection from future
infections and of course this protection
is also the ultimate goal of all
vaccination strategies that are being
developed against zaskov 2 and therefore
monitoring
of these zaskov to specific tnb cells
could actually help us to understand the
efficacy of all these covid-19 vaccines
however there are also many other
research applications where these cells
could be analyzed for example for the
identification of asymptomatic positive
patients or also for the development of
therapeutic antibodies
and we will see a lot more of these
applications on the following slides
so while it's definitely very important
to analyze the entire immune responses
ask of to infection it is particularly
critical to focus really on the
cellulite responses so in this case
disaster of two specific tnb cells
because monitoring of these cells
actually allows us to understand disease
progression or also analyze the
vaccination status and this is mainly
because actually I've said it before
because this tnb cells play such a
critical role in generating
immunological memory that ultimately
protects us from future infections and
of course this is also the goal of all
the different vaccinations that have
been developed against Sask of tool
and therefore it's also not surprising
that already several studies have
examined the role of these tasks of this
two specific tnb cells after vaccination
to really be able to pinpoint and also
analyze the efficacy of all these
different covid-19 vaccines and one
common methods that is often used to
analyze these tnb cells is actually flow
cytometry so for example researchers
that analyze T cells often focus on the
expression of certain activation markers
or also cytokines such as interlocking 2
or interferon gamma
and we will have a closer look at the
different analysis methods on the
following slides
so at military biotech we have developed
really fantastic tools to allow you to
study the task of two specific tnb cells
in much more detail so for example it's
ask of two specific T cells are usually
activated by peptides derived from
disaskov to virus that are loaded onto
MHC molecules that are expressed on
antigen presenting cells for example on
dendritic cells but also on on Infected
cells for example so here we will take a
closer look at our zaskov to pep divider
peptide pools which we actually offer
for all the major structures ask of two
proteins like for example a spike
protein
in the case of the B cells it's a bit
different so they can for example
recognize also the uh the intact virus
or the full length um zaskov to derive
proteins and then eventually the Visa
will become a plasma cell that will
start to secrete ask of to specific
antibody so to really study is ask of
two specific B cells or also antibodies
in much more detail we will take a look
at our zaskov to antigens which are full
lengths and proteins that we offer
either in a biotinylated or
unbiotinrelated version to really allow
analysis as well as enrichment of the
ask of two specific B cells
so the task of two specific T cells can
actually be described as being antigen
specific but how can we find that let's
say more general definition of antigen
specific T cells well in principle of
course all T cells are somewhat antigen
specific however when we talk about
antigen specific pieces that militantly
we actually think of cells that were
activated by a specific antigen for
example a viral peptide in vitro and
this is really in stark contrast to
polyclonal activation via CD3 cd28
within this large pool of T cells the
actual frequency of T cells that will
respond to the specific antigen is very
very low so we should keep in mind here
that antigen specific T cells are in
general very rare cells the antigen
specific stimulation will also trigger
Cell Activation meaning the upregulation
of certain activation markers like for
example c25 cd69 or cd154 and also
induced cytokine secretion like here
team of alphar or also gamma interferon
furthermore these antidote specific T
cells will also expand following
stimulation
of course their study is highly
important in both basic and clinical
research as they play critical role in
various infectious diseases during
vaccine development or also fundamental
inhuman Immunology autoimmune diseases
or also allergic diseases
so how can we analyze antidote and
virus-specific T cells in more detail
well in general the methods can actually
be classified into two main categories
so first is the direct analysis of
T-cell specificity using for example
fluorescently labeled peptide MSC
multimeters this peptide MHC multimeters
will bind specifically only to a certain
tza receptor and then allow a clear
identification of for example
virus-specific T cells using flow
cytometry so why this method certainly
provide the higher specificity it also
comes with certain limitations for
example it works very well for cd8
positive T cells but only limited for
CD4 positive T cells furthermore you
will not produce any information on the
function capacity or the TSA subsets and
it's also limited to really Define
peptides and also works best for only
certain MHC molecules
in addition we also have the indirect
analysis methods which really focus on
functional parameters of T-cell
Activation so for example the production
of certain cytokines also the upper
regulation of specific surface
activation markers but we could also
analyze t-set proliferation for example
so here we indirectly identify antigen
reactive T cells after antigen specific
stimulation in redrow and the good thing
is that these methods really work well
for all TSA subsets also including
antigen specific regulatory T cells they
will provide these as subset specific
information and are mostly independent
of the used antigen for stimulation and
also the analyzed donor our best thing
is that all these methods will be
analyzed using floss automatic
approaches
so before we dive into the workflow
let's have a quick look into the key
challenges that might arise when you
work with this very rare cells and how
we can help you to overcome them so for
example when you work with antigen
specific T cells from tissues you might
be limited by the amount of starting
material so our gentlemax tissue
dissociator can really help you to
efficiently prepare your sample in the
first place and make sure that you don't
lose these cells from the beginning
also an insufficient in vitro
stimulation could be a big problem
especially for all of these in vitro
stimulation essays so essays where T
cells are stimulated with the engine of
interest in vitro so here we have
developed a really powerful stimulation
reagents and also several optimized
protocols that will help you to make
sure that your cells are efficiently
stimulated
also the low frequency of these very
rare antigen specific T cells of often
below 0.1 percent
will make a reliable flow analysis
really difficult so here you can use our
Max technology to magnetically
pre-enrich these cells before analysis
so as I've just said the cells are often
analyzed by flow cytometry and this is
often difficult due to the High
backgrounds High background staining
just because these cells are so rare
however here with our recombinant
reaffinity antibodies that actually have
been designed keeping flow cytometry in
mind in combination with our really
sensitive Max square and flow cytometers
you can make sure that you detect even
the rarest T cells
and finally there's often a rather slow
translation of early research findings
into the clinic
and here we offer a very large portfolio
of translational research products for
example we have the max Quan title sales
order that really allows the GMP
compliant cell sorting or also the
cleaning Max Prodigy system that
performs a completely automated cell
processing in a in a closed and also
sterile system
so we actually combine these different
Technologies then in an entire workflow
and we strongly believe
that the right product combination here
is the key to success
so here you can see a schematic drawing
of the complete workflow for the
analysis of these rare cells so of
course first T cells would need to be
isolated from a donor sample and this
could be tissue Blood also pvmcs for
tissue dissociation of course the
gentlemax tissue dissociator is a really
good choice especially in combination
with our tissue dissociation kits
next the cells are simulated with the
antigen of interest in neutral and here
it's really important to know that
antigen presenting cells will also need
to be present during the stimulation to
really ensure efficient activation of
the isolated T cells with the specific
antigen if you work with pbmcs it's
really nice because this is already the
case it contains anti-representing cells
as well as T cells however if you work
with isolated T cells you need you need
to add the antigen presenting cells
separately
following the stimulation only the
antigen specific T cells will get
activated and the cells can then be
stained intra and also extracellularly
to assess for example the phenotype or
also analyze cytokine expression
and then before cell analysis you can
also magnetically pre-enrich these
anti-interactive T cells using really
specific cell surface activation markers
and then finally the cells are analyzed
either using floss autometry or also
other methods you can use here our Max
Quant floss autometer for analysis or
also sort of cells for example with our
Max Squad title cell Soldier
so let's have a look at the different
workflow steps on the following slides
when you work with antigen specific
t-shirts often everything starts with
pvmcs and you probably know that
successful experiments usually start
actually with efficient sample
preparation
so usually pbmcs are actually prepared
via density gradient centrifugation
however when you work with let's say
compromised samples contaminated samples
or also very small samples these density
gradient centrifugation methods can be
very tedious inefficient and in some
cases also dangerous especially when you
work with infectious material
so here we offer actually two
alternative solutions that provide a
really fast and untouched magnetic
isolation of Highly pure pbmcs with a
very high recovery so first we have the
so-called Max Prep pvmc isolation kit
which really completely eliminates any
user-dependent inconsistencies
to really ensure that you have a
reliable separation every time you
isolate pvmcs
and you can also see the um the
isolation of pbmcs here on the graph
where we compared pbmc isolation using
the kit with density gradient
centrifugation the kit is actually
optimized for very small blood samples
so 1 to 10 10 milliliters that will be
easily processed in 25 minutes and you
will get highly pure pbmcs the kit is
also zme automatable with our multi-max
cell 24 so you can isolate pbmcs from a
higher number of samples and then use
the pbmcs in any Downstream um or any
any functional Downstream essays
so next we have the so-called whole
blood pbmc isolation kit which uses the
exact same technology as the max prep
kit but is fully scalable also for large
blood samples and it's also fully
automatable with the Auto Max Pro
instrument in this case so again after
isolation these untouched pvmcs can then
be used directly for any kind of of
Downstream essays like also RNA
sequencing for example or as a it's a
good starting point for the magnetic
enrichment of other immune cell subsets
so really the high speed the ease of use
the full automatability and also the
safety is fixed
make these pvmc isolation
Solutions here really valuable for for
as a starting point for your antigen
specific these workflow
so for the really efficient in vitro
simulation of antigen specific t-codes
we offer the so-called peptivater
peptide pools
these peptivada peptide pools are
designed to ensure a really highly
efficient stimulation of both CD4
positive as well as cd8 positive T cells
and here we actually cover a very
extensive portfolio also a growing
portfolio a virus two more fungi
microbiota and also some Auto antigens
the peptide Foods always consist of 50
meepeptides with an 11 amino acid
overlap and here we cover actually
complete sequence of the respective
antigen
the activators are available in three
different grades so we have here
research premium or also Max GMP grade
which will allow a rapid translation of
finding into the clinic and finally the
peptide pools are also available in High
throughput version in a very convenient
96 well format to allow more let's say
high throughput application
so we think that the expected pepticals
are actually the idle stimulation
reagents for the simulation of antigen
and virus specific T cells
and of course we also offer our
pactivated peptide Foods specifically
designed for the activation of zaskov to
specific T cells and here on your side
you can actually see a simplified image
of disaster of two virus which
highlights some of the most important
viral proteins where the immune system
so in this case the T cells can actually
attack
so here we offer various research grades
asked of to Pepto peptide pools directed
against the spike protein which will
also be soon available in premium weight
which was actually more than 80 Purity
as well as the nuclear and membrane
protein
we're also continuously releasing new
pep dividers for all these different
zask of fumutation variants and here
it's good to know that we actually have
two peptide pools per variant so we have
a mutation pool that covers the mediated
sequence of course and the respective
control pool
and by stimulating your T cells with the
mutation and this reference control pool
you are able to really detect
mutation-specific user responses and
then also directly compare them to the
wild types of to virus
and finally we also recently added the
so-called zaskov to prepubator select
and it's the this this select paper
dividers actually pool of 88 peptides
which cover the entire immunodominant
epitopes of the zaskov to proteome
and here it's really good to know that
this ask of two pept evader select is
already available in both premium as
well as Max GMP grade so we think that
with this ask of to Pepto peptide pools
you are actually
able to really ensure efficient
stimulation and also analysis of zask of
two reactive T cells
yes and indeed stimulation with ours ask
of to peptovelopeptide puts results in
the efficient activation of in this case
CD3 positive T cells so here in this
example blood samples of a healthy donor
and a covid-19 convalescent donor were
lies with an RBC license platform and
then stimulated for four hours with the
indicated the ask of two peptivater as a
controller we left the cells untreated
sales were then stain following
stimulation using an optimized intro and
accessor level standing protocol and or
flow panel that we specifically
developed for the analysis of the ask of
directive T cells so to assess the
antigen specific or in this case these
ask of two specific activation we gated
on interference gamma producing CD3
positive T cells and as the plots here
clearly show the covid-19 convalescent
donor actually presents an elevated
number level of task of directive T
cells following a stimulation with the
pept evader and we're also nicely
Quantified that here in a bar graph on
the side where you see the percentage of
interferon gamma positive CD3 positive T
cells in these two donor groups
following the different stimulation with
these task of two pept evaders and you
can see that actually combination of the
nuclear protein membrane protein and
Spike protein shows the highest response
so of course flow cytometry is still the
most widely used method for the analysis
of these rare antigen specific T cells
however even established methods like
flosser dormitory still have certain
limits and challenges
and this was already Illustrated and
analyzed years ago in a very nice
publication by Petra Baka and colleagues
that you can see here on the site where
the authors clearly state that despite
this High sensitivity of floss Optometry
it is always limited by the number of
events that can be acquired
as well as the um the standing
background which is typically for
antigen specific T cells between let's
say 0.01 and 0.1 percent so this really
restricts a reliable analysis of say
populations with low frequencies
so actually in in most instances some of
these modern super modern flaws
automators actually sensitive enough to
detect at least some cells there might
be certain stimulation conditions for
example where you can hardly detect any
specific cell
so to help you overcome these low cell
frequencies you can actually use our Max
microbeads for pre-enrichment
furthermore to help you overcome this
High background staining and enable a
higher resolution analysis you can use
our reaffinity recombinant antibodies
which provide a really high specificity
and also Superior lock to load
consistencies coupled with our bio dice
they really ensure a very bright
staining a crisp signal with a very low
spillover
so we actually think that magnetic
pre-enrichment and also this recombinant
antibodies are here the key for
successful analysis of rare cells
the max technology actually comes in
four different approaches to really
reflect all different starting materials
there might be so first we have the
microbeads and also the micro bit kits
that are really perfect for the positive
T-cell isolation from pbmcs but also
from various other tissue single cell
suspensions they also include the new
realist technology which allow a
label-free cell separation
second we have the isolation kits that
are really idle for all untouched
separation needs so this is a negative
isolation and here use starting
materials as pbmcs or other defined
single cell suspensions so here you
really need to know the composition of
your cell suspension for both approaches
we actually cover basic T Cell subsets
as well as almost any subtype from
different species like human Mouse red
and also non-human primates however if
you want to skip density gradient
centrifugation to get your pbmcs you can
also isolate T cells fast and also
directly from Whole blood so here is the
third option we have the so-called
straight from microbead kits for the
positive isolation of human cd3s before
in cd8 T cells and so just straight from
the really nice way to get your T cells
in a super fast and reliable way
and it's also automatable last but not
least we also have the so-called Max
Express isolation kits for an untouched
isolation of human T cells also directly
from Whole blood which this Max Express
there's also no need for density
gradient centrifugation to get the pbmcs
however here a column 3 approach is used
and in contrast to other Technologies
Max Express is not automatable but still
very fast and also very uncomplicated to
use
of course we also offer microbead kits
for the specific enrichment of antigen
activated T cells and here in this
example we actually used cd154 or cd-137
microbit kids to enrich either CD4
positive with cd1054 or cd8 positive T
cells with cd1 on 37 microbead kits and
we actually recommend to UC 154 for
antigen activated CD4 positive T Cell
enrichment and cd-1 on 3740 enrichment
of antigen activated cd8 positive T
cells so in this example here pbmcs were
stimulated with the CMV pp65 prepubator
and then we use the respective kits to
enrich antigen activated T cells and we
left the cells untreated as a negative
control and as you can see no c154 or C1
or 37 positive cells could be enriched
in the unsimulated control however
following stimulation with the peptide
peptide pool the antigen specific CD4
positive T cells were successfully
enriched using the c154 micro bit kit
here on the very right whereas the cd8
positive T cells were successfully
enriched using the cv-137 microbead kit
the isolated cells can then be used for
any Downstream applications
like for example a sequencing of diesel
receptors and if you also want to know
more I really recommend you to to look
at our very nice technology paper here
on the top right which really
illustrates the technology and its use
in much more detail
so furthermore I also want to point out
a cell separation product that is really
really unique the so-called cytokine
secretion essays which allow a viable
enrichment of cytokine secreting T cells
from Mouse and human samples and the
actual principle of the essay you can
see it here on the left side is really
simple so first the secreted cytokines
are immobilized on the cellular Surface
by the so-called catch reagent and
thereby the cell
um basically labels itself with its own
cytokines then in the second step
in the immobilized cytokines are labeled
as a floor for conjugated antibody
called the detection radiant and then
allows detection using conventional
floss optometry in an optional third
step the cells can also be enriched and
used in in any Downstream essays
with the help of an anti-floroform
magnetic bead and then using our Max
technology so this is also why we
actually have two different versions of
the kits so for flow analysis only we
have here the so-called detection kits
in PE APC and fits available for various
human and urine cytokines
and for the enrichment as well as
detection of cytokine secreting cells we
have the so-called enrichment
anti-taction kits which are all
available
in PE
and also for various human as well as
murine cytokines
please also don't forget that if you
want to isolate antigen or virus
specific T cells in a clinical setting
we also offer the so-called cytokine
capture system which is running on our
cleaning Max Prodigy platform so here
actually first experiments regarding
adaptive cell therapy in covid-19 were
performed with research grades asked of
two peptida peptide pools however now
you're actually ready for the next steps
with our Max stream p-peptivators ask of
to select
in addition the cleaning Mark system can
also be used for the depletion of cd45
for our positive T cells to produce a
ready-to-use cell product
and actually its applicability has been
recently demonstrated interface one dose
escalation study by Antonio Perez
Martinez and colleagues
who used the cleaning Mark City 45 air
depletion for the treatment of covet 19.
so for flow phenotyping I would like to
briefly talk about actually one of my
favorite products when it comes to the
analysis of antigen specific T cells and
these are the reaffinity recombinant
antibodies coupled to our biodies I
really have to say here that these
antibodies have been designed keeping
flow cytometry in mind
so this reaffinity recombinant
antibodies are actually completely
recommendently engineered with actually
which actually means that we have a full
control over the genetic makeup and we
can easily express them in mammalian
non-hybridoma cell systems and this also
means that these antibodies have a
higher Purity and Superior not to lot
consistency compared to monoclonal
hybridoma antibodies
reaffinity recommended antibodies
provide a really low background staining
um which makes them actually a perfect
tool for for real cell analysis in
general
and our biodies are actually our very
own fluorescent diets that work really
well in conjunction with the reaffinity
antibodies they of course have a very
high stain index very low spillover
provide a very crisp signal and allow a
clear discrimination of these very rare
cell populations
of course we have this reaffinity
recombinant antibodies for all the
conventional T Cell markers but also
including diesel activation
proliferation or exhaustion markers
um we also have them for cytokines and
other T Cell markers and we are also
always happy to help you designing your
very own flow panel
so the recommended reaffinity antibodies
are also included in our new zaskov to T
Cell analysis kits which can be used for
the stimulation as well as analysis of
humans ask of two reactive T cells in
both pbmcs or other whole blood samples
the kids are really designed let's say
as an as an all-in-one solution that
contain all irradions for stimulation
all the buffers antibodies for staining
and the positive control to really allow
you to directly start with your
experiment
and here on the on the side you can
actually see the workflow so you would
either start from from Whole blood or
pbmc's stimulate your cells with a
included zasp of two Pepto Veda peptide
pool and then prepare and stain your
cells for flow analysis
so the the cells can actually be
analyzed on any conventional floss
automata but of course work really good
on our Max Quant analyzers
and it's also good to know that we offer
one version of the kit that does not
contain a zask of two peptoyota peptide
pool but here you can choose your your
own simulation reagents or also combine
these kids with different pepticator
peptide pool to also analyze other
antigen specificities
so of course also here I've brought you
some accent query data sorry
so in this example here we actually use
the task of 2D cell analysis kits to
stimulate and stain pbmcs of a covid-19
convalescent donor so first the cells
were stimulated with the indicators ask
of two peptogether peptide pools so for
example the nuclear protein protein n or
the membrane protein also the spike
protein we used a mixture of CMV and ABV
pepcubators as a positive control all
after cells unsimulated as a negative
control following stimulation we then
stain the cells with this optimized
antibody panel that is included in all
of our kits and we use we also stain
cb69 in this Free PE vial 615 Channel
so the cells were then recorded on our
Max con 16 analyzer
and then and then analyzed so for the
analysis we actually here pre-gated
either on CD4 you need the upper row or
on cd8 unilor roll and to assess
t-select duration we actually focused on
CD 154 and tnf Alpha for the activated
C4 positive T cells or on cd69 and Gamma
interferon on cd8 positive D cells and
as you can see here his ask of directive
teeth so it's actually responded very
specifically to the stimulation
especially with the amp activator but
also with the spike protein pepcubator
and this then just just simply indicates
an exposure of the donor to disaster
cov2 virus and you can nicely
discriminate these responses using this
optimized antibody panel and in addition
you could also use the kit for example
to detect a vaccine-specific response
where you would focus on the um response
you would you would get with the spike
protein
so apart from disaskov to T-cell
analysis kits we also offer other really
convenient complete kits for flow
cytometric analysis for example we have
the so-called rapid cytokine inspectors
which allow rapid multi-parameter
analysis of those activated as well as
CDA positive T cells directly from fresh
human whole Blood also premium C samples
and here the kids actually enable you in
a to do a one-step protection of both
surface markers and intracellular
cytokines
so also we also have the so-called
maxplex cytokine kits available for both
human and mouse samples and they allow a
multiplex analysis of several soluble
cytokines so for example up to 12 human
or 10 urine cytokines in just one sample
so for example say culture supernatant
and the kids also work basically on
every standard flow cytometer and last
but not least we have also have the
so-called eight Color immuno phenotyping
Kit which really enables you to do um a
flow-based evaluation of various Lucas
at subsets for example from pbmcs also
from Human whole blood to really
reliably identify for example monocytes
neutrophils eosinophils tnb cells as
well as NK cell populations
and all of those kits here are actually
compatible with our so-called flow
Express modes which are available on all
our Max Quant analyzers and you can
imagine these flow Express modes as some
kind of software module that allows you
to perform an automated analysis of data
that are generated with these kits and
if you want to have more information I
would recommend you to check out these
webinars that we've created on these
kits and express modes that you can find
here on the on the lower right
yeah so our flow portfolio is actually
rounded off with our own flow analysis
and flow sorting instruments of the
so-called Max Quan Series so here on the
left side we see a Max one analyzer 16
which is a really powerful benchtop loss
automator and allows you to analyze up
to 16 Optical parameters
and yeah for me here really the clue is
that the max coin analyzers allow a
fully automated sample acquisition as
well as data analysis using these
Express mode software modules that are
available for a lot of our flow
phenotyping kits and furthermore it's
small size really allows to place these
flow cytometers basically under any
conventional fluid which then further
adds to operator safety which is
especially important when you work with
let's say contaminated samples
and then here on the right side we see
the max one title sales order which
opposed to classical droplets orders
actually uses this unique cartridge for
sorting so it has a unique microchip
technology
and therefore it allows really gender
and also fast sorting and ensures the
highest viability of even very fragile
sales such as virus specific t or B
cells
and furthermore the the closed and
steroid cartridge system that you also
see here on the right side actually make
the tie to the idle instrument for any
GMP environment
so here you can see a schematic overview
of the entire antigen and virus specific
teaser portfolio and workflow so here
you actually recognize that we offer
products for the whole workflow so
really from sample preparation to cell
culture to cell separation and also cell
analysis and of course you will find
much more information on our website
so last but not least I would just like
to briefly mention that military biotech
offers a really large product portfolio
to allow a smooth transition from
research to clinical applications so I
have now shown you our research
solutions for the analysis of antigen
specific T cells in the context of
zaskov 2 research and now Kirsten will
show you how to use cell therapy to
fight infections so Kirsten the stage is
yours
Cell Therapy products based on virus
specific donor T cells have been used to
treat opportunistic viral infections in
the context of allergenic hematopoietic
Stamford transplantation
it has been discussed whether this
treatment option could also be applied
to covid-19 patients in this context I
would like to present the work of three
different groups from Singapore the
United Kingdom and Spain
as the authors explain these
Publications the transient presence of
donating cells in covid-19 patients
could be possible under certain
conditions
on the other hand it would be imperative
to prevent anoreactive reactions against
the patient
most antibiotic offers workflows for the
production of cell products that are
used in certain cases to prevent or
treat opportunistic infections in
patients after allergenic hematopoietic
stem cell transplantation
in the Publications the users describe
how these workers could be used to
produce Cell Therapy products against
Sask of 2 infections
first some background information on T
Cell based cell service infections
this treatment was originally developed
in the context of electronic
hematobiotic sensor transplantation
until the reconstitution of the new
immune system these patients are at high
risk for opportunistic viral infections
such as infections with CMB ADV or bkv
antivirus drug resistant cases have been
treated with adaptive T Cell Therapy
metanibiotech provides tools for
manufacturing T Cell based products that
are used to treat certain viral
infections in allergenic hematopoietic
Sunset transplantation
for 17 years the clinical application of
these treatment options has been
continuously published in peer review
journals by now new ways to treat
covid-19 patients with adoptive T-cell
therapy under certain conditions have
been described
let us start with the concept of
transferring very specific T cells to
combat certain viral diseases
as reported adoptive transfer of
allergenic VCS can rapidly destroy a
very specific immunity and control viral
infections after alternate external
transplantation
sources of very specific T cells may
include
stem cell donated reference specific T
cells as in Arsenic Orthopedic sensor
transplantation
this is the majority of cases and there
are also reports on third-party donor
derived very specific T-cells which have
been used in patients with infections
after sorted organ transplantation
the production of antiviral diesel
products requires the enrichment of
relevant very specific T cells and
depletion of potentially atereactive T
cells
there are several strategies to produce
these products as for example those that
are based on xvideo expansion
another option is provided by The
cleanmax Prodigy cytokine capture system
from multinibiotic
for this option it is necessary to find
a convalescent donor for the desired
viral Target
how does a clean Max cytokine capture
system work within the cleaning and
astrology process
the cleaners produce process integrates
all critical steps of the CCS workflow
from antigen specific T-cell simulation
to labeling of target cells magnetic
isolation and final formulation within
12 hours of Total time importantly all
cell processing steps are automated
ensuring a convenient and highly
standardized separation process these
include simulation of the starting
product from a convalescent donor with a
viral specific peptide to activate the
desired VST separation of these cells by
other intervalent gamma secretion and
the Magnetic separation strategy to a
rich interference gamma-producing cells
recently we have launched a Max 3MP pep
divider targeting the ask of two
specific peptides furthermore we will be
glad to provide the reference list with
clinical applications of the cleaning
marks cytokine capture system
all necessary consumable for this
procedure are supplied by military
biotech
the cleaner Max Prodigy CCS interval and
Gamma system is available as a CE Mark
medical device application outside the
EU Regional legislations and
irregulations are applied
the clinical use of a cell product is
subject to Regional legislation and is
under the responsibility of the user
let us now take a look at the second
possibility of producing T-cell products
against certain infections
the owner derived CT 45 already created
Fair products have been used in the
field of alginate hematopoietic sensor
transplantation memory t-shirts provide
immunity against many viral infections
that the donor has experienced during
his lifetime
prior to clinical application it was
shown in Mouse models that the other
reactive potential is high in the
naivetizer compartment and significantly
reduced into MLT compartment
prehymock City 45 gray depleted Fair
products I used to treat orbitalastic
infections and to enhance immune
pre-constitution in the setting of
allergenic stencil transportation
cd45 array is an ISO form of the cd45
family that is present 100 of naive T
cells but not on cd-450 positive Central
and effective memory T cells
it is also present on approximately 100
of B cells 80 percent of MK cells and 30
of monocytes
cd45 array is not a duplicate T Cell
marker but it is an ideal marker to
deplete other reactivity from a product
in one step leaving specific memory T
cells with the given benefits and thus
representing an excellent production
option for clinical applications
mercenary biotech offers two technical
options for the clinical grade depletion
of cd45 array positive cells from
nuclear Services products performed on
either the kmax plus device or The
kinemax Prodigy device so starting
fracturers labeled as antibodies
targeting the surface marker ct45ra
magnetic separation results in a Target
reflection passively enriched for memory
T cells the Clearman's class cd45 system
has been released the market in 2011.
please contact us if you would like to
receive the full list of references for
this application
consumable for these procedures are
supplied by military biotech 2ce
certified medical device applications
are available for depletion of cd45 for
repositive results the cleaner Max Plus
cd45 array system provides a
semi-automated procedure for starting
products containing up to 50 times 10 to
the nine white blood cells the cleaning
Max Prodigy pv45 array system provides a
fully automated process for smaller
seller bounds in the starting material
in addition to luciferous products whole
blood can also be used as starting
material with the system
outside the EU Regional legislations and
regulations are applied the clinical use
of the cell product is subject to
Regional legislation and is under the
responsibility of the user
several groups have developed
manufacturing processes for sale
products and convalescent Donuts
targeting zask of two infections he
present TS3 Publications in which these
new developments are described they are
all open access papers
being Leo and his co-workers describe a
process for flexible and Rapid
manufacturing of vsts once a donor is
available this option uses the climax
cytokine capture system the publication
from Cuba adult coming from the UK
describes a process that also starts
with the enrichment of fire specific tea
sets using the claim exciting capture
system the difference to the previous
publication is that here the culturing
step is added to increase the Harvest of
these teeth
the final product can be provided within
a biobank a third-publication by
researchers from Spain also describes a
generation of cell products for
biobanking however here manual piece of
products are provided that are generated
using the cleaning Max Plus cd45 array
system
infusion of these cells in covid-19
patients have been previously published
by Antonio Perris and his collaborators
I would not like to briefly present this
important Publications however due to
the large amount of information
contained in this publication I will
only briefly touch on selected points to
get a complete picture of this important
projects I recommend reading the
original Publications
the two objectives of the study by being
Leon and collaborators were to
investigate whether sufficient numbers
of Sask of two specific T-cells are
present in the blood of convalescent
donors another important point was to
investigate whether it is possible to
produce clinical grade products
overnight
all blood or lucophoresis products were
collected from the convalescent donors
and Buffy Coats were prepared from the
whole blood samples
products and puffy Coats were stimulated
with overlapping peptides or south of
specific s and of M proteins the
stimulated products were processed by
clinium oxidecon capture system
procedures and the resulting fractions
the analyzed for the amount of interform
gamma-producing cells the phenotype
diesel receptor the better specificity
and functionality
the enrichment procedures resulted in
final products that contained a median
of 0.98 times 10 to the 6 84 gamma
positive T cells
to demonstrate functionality one of the
samples was successfully restimulated
was peptide loaded to undertake salts
subgroup analysis revealed a relative
depletion of naive sea salts and an
enrichment of effective minorities of in
the enriched fractions suggesting that
other activity was reduced
piece of receptor the better
spectrotyping showed Market Lehigh
Oliver clone repeats in the final
products
we also concluded that overnight
production of clinical grade zask of two
specific T cells is feasible for
therapeutic purposes
the other reactive potential was reduced
while virus specific tea sets were
retained in the product
we also suggest that the dosage of 5
times 10 to the 3 is ask of two specific
T cells per kilogram based on previously
administer cell members in other
clinical settings
under this assumption one unit of full
blood could be sufficient to produce
three to six products for adult
recipients
you also know that based on previous
Studies by other authors very specific
T-shirts from donors who shared only one
HLA molecule are effective
based on this information for the six
donors in the study the probability of
potential patients having at least one
HLA match would be more than 88 for
Caucasians 95 for Chinese
97 for my lace and 99 for Indians
populations
all this and much more details can be
found in the original publication as
given below
the group of John Campo and his
collaborators is featured in the
forthcoming publication by Rachel
Cooperative the goal of the study was to
characterize Cask of two peptide
specific memories of populations in
convalescent donors in addition the
authors aim to investigate the
feasibility of isolating and expounding
these results on a clinical scale using
an integrated cell culture step
the experimental design included a
scaled up experiments functional testing
of the obtained cells and experiments
comparing blood from convalescent donors
with blood from donors who have not
underground Vasco of 2 infection
important findings of this study are the
generation of infra on gamma responses
and zaskov 2 very specific tea sets from
convalescent donors is possible after
peptide stimulation isolation and
expansion
another important finding water the
presence of HLA class 1 and 2 Alliance
is widespread in the UK population and
that some specific HLA subtypes with a
strong pepclair presentation ability
were identified
finally the authors concluded that their
method for generating large amount of
very specific teaser products is
feasible for clinical trials supporting
severe risk of two infections is
comprised into genius T Cell response
you can get an idea of the production
method developed by John Campbell and
his collaborators in Edinburgh UK
to begin with a look of a resource
product is obtained from a convalescent
donor the very specific T cells
contained therein are stimulated and
enriched with the cleanmax Prodigy CCS
interval gamma system and appropriates
ask of two specific patterns the
Harvesters ask a few specific t-shirts
are then captured for 21 days this
irradiated cells from the non-target
cell fraction as fetal cells
as indicated the final chloride contains
between 10 to the 10th and 10 to the
11th cells
we stimulating experience with synthetic
cells demonstrated viral specific T Cell
functionality after cultivation
the final product is then Frozen and can
be stored in a biopank system
after 14 days of expand room Central
memory cd40 CD4 positive cells are the
predominant subtypes
furthermore and have stated the expanded
very specific teasers showed negligible
co-expression of T Cell exhaustion
markers pd1 and tip 3 in both
the CD4 and cd8 compartment indicating
the character expansion has not induced
an exhaust system or type
all these and much more details can be
found in the origin publication as given
below
Antonio Perez and his collaborators from
Spain have developed a different method
for delivering Cell Therapy products to
covid-19 patients they use kmax City 45
for education to generate products that
are stored within a code 19 biobank from
convalescent donors
an important question was whether that's
a full specific manual pieces exists in
convalescent donors and whether they can
be enriched by City 45 array depletion
this was shown in experience this pbmcs
from uninfected and convalescent donors
in simulation experiments with three
peptides of the S and the M protein
interform gamma circuiting cd45 Ro
positive T cells were detected in
convalescent donors but not in
uninfected donors
a clinical scale product was generated
using the clean Max Plus cd45 array
system
again interform gamma secreting ct45 are
all positive cells could be generated in
the Target satisfaction
to check functionality after freezing
and thawing the final product was frozen
and thought and stimulated this
interlocking 15 for 72 hours and the
subsequent phenotropic essay revealed a
phenotype characteristic of an activated
state
here we can get an overview of the
production process
a look of a resource product was
obtained from a convalescent donor as
reported after a cleaner Max Plus cd45
depletion procedure 80 percent also
sells the city 45 array negativity cells
around 84 of the t-shirts were CD4
positive and about 14 to 38 positive
simulation with task of two specific
platforms the percentage of interferent
gamma secreting cells and the T Cell
subsets range from 0.31 to 0.38 percent
the predominant phenotype or Central
memory T cells all this and much more
details can be found in the original
Publications as given below
recently the Youth of cd45 already
depleted memory T cells in the treatment
of covid-19 patients has been reported
by Antonio Perez and his co-workers
within a phase 1 clinical trial
participants were hospitalized patients
with PCR confirmed task of two
infections and according to further
inclusion criteria regarding polynomial
lymphopenia and oxygen demand
enrollment was based on match with the
HLA genotype of the convalescent donor
and according to inclusion exclusion
criteria signal infusions were applied
in the dose escalating manner 10
patients were enrolled in nine patients
were treated
three patients each received three
escalating doses ranging from 1 times 10
to the 5 cells per kilogram over 5 times
10 to the 5 cells per kilogram up to 1
times 26 cells per kilogram of City 45a
negative memory T cells
they also stated that this study
provided preliminary evidence supporting
the idea that treatment of covid-19
patients with smaller rate to severe
symptoms using convalescence cd45 array
negative memory presets was feasible and
safe
this clinical application is being
further investigated in a Facebook
clinical trial all this and much more
details can be found in the original
publication as given below
with that we end today's webinar and
thank you for your attention if you have
other questions please contact us via
email
thank you Lawrence and Kirsten for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
what is the main difference between cell
products obtained by the CCS system and
cd45ra depletion
thankful thank you I hope you can hear
me um yes I'd like to answer that
question so the difference is that the
manual Visa product is obtained by
Infinity step and that's the product is
therefore quickly available so there's
no those activities it's not necessary
um inside the patient the manual trees
also become activated in case of a viral
infection and uh the depletion of 45
array leads to an almost complete active
diffusion of the Ft cells that are
mainly responsible for for other
activity or VISA body plated and besides
the memory presets only few and K cells
are preserved and most of the monocytes
and general sizes those products
from September assaults of City 45
positive and and they are therefore
excluded
um and the CCS UF products are generated
after
exposure to virus specific peptides and
at least to a section of pure T cells or
mainly purt cells but they are also
passively depleted of naivets because
it means both
sometimes get a
um a fraction of cells that is depleted
of safety cells either actively or
personally for bios products are safe
thank you next question do you have
protocols for the flow analysis of T
Cell fractions
um yes if you have so we have for both
applications you have flow protocols you
have
um they have a flow protocol for the
policy analysis of City photographer ID
create yourself
and to have furthermore a pre-installed
program on the max Cloud to measure
yourself after this one from our
secretion essay so until
um say that the method that you can use
this our fluorocytometer device Max
Squad that we have not only a protocol
but only a pre-inspired program to run
that
hey and it looks like we have time for
one more question
why why is the clinomax plus a
semi-automatic automated application
which steps are not automated
uh well so yes
um the clear Maps plus uh
um does not have possibilities to do all
the cell matchings before the magnetic
separation for the um those flushing
steps and the addition of silver
statistic labeling reagent and labeling
procedure and washing steps after that
they are all done manually with a back
centrifuge
I've attend the magnetic separation
procedure is entirely automated of the
cleaner Max Plus that's the difference
to The Prodigy the priority offers a
complete automation also for the rushing
steps and the mathematic labeling crops
well thank you Lorenz and Kirsten for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor milteni biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye